hello everyone we're going to start the
class the 7:30 class and I prepared this
game to show you the game as part of
nurses to follow very famous game where
casparo sacrificed many pieces and drove
blacks King from a seven all the way to
d1 in order to win there were some
really spectacular moves played here and
the game started with E for d6 d4 Knight
f6 I mean the very courageous opening
choice by de pollo because as part of
opening choice was very very strong
always and playing the pork against him
was certainly a little bit risky but he
did play well in this game and even
though he lost the game he found a lot
of great defensive moves and I think in
some point he had chances to perhaps
equalize the game so that's what it's
doing yes
I'm seasoning yeah well
Quezada was very strong with the white
pieces and you know use these openings
are very strong and this opening is
little risky because it's one of the
Nahuatl domain openings
okay so Knight c3 protecting the pawn
central pawn now it goes qi6
Bishop III I will go a little bit faster
in the opening here Queen d2 c 6f 3 this
is a standard move in this position to
protect efore to stop all the Nigeria's
and at some point white is getting ready
to play the move Bishop to h6 okay so b5
yeah 9g to white issues developing
developing his pieces 9b d7 Bishop h6
activating the bishop and putting some
pressure on g7 takes Queen takes h6 we
should be seventh Apollo is developing
his bishops now Bishop now I'm just
trying to get his development a three
important move a three to prevent the
move before okay so the point is a three
to play d4 so now he cannot play before
you because you'll capture it
'if i buy to pull off trying to
challenge White's Center because white
is a very good control of the center so
it's trying to use to play a five to
make sure it's challenging the center
okay goes long castle logical move to
put the rook on a D file here if takes
you take back with the night for example
Queen e7 king b1 why does it play King
b1 here we can explain the reason why he
spent that move here to play king b1 and
what kind of movies can be one here
prophylactic move yes yes why did he
breaking b1
and you don't want your team there and
also diagonal yeah Oh see file we don't
know yet at the moment maybe it will
open maybe not but it's just if somehow
Queens Nixon on a2 is going to be a big
problem yeah it could be some checkmate
on it oh so you play this prophylactic
move too awesome away from the diagonal
it's from general point of view it's
it's just much better placed here and
nothing concrete is going on here so he
wants to put the King here and one more
thing this move is going to allow white
later in the game is to use the C 1 V 3
square for the knight that has so
everybody understand why King be one is
played okay what do you mean why he
doesn't want to stay on a D file your
queen is going to be pinned here it's
Kinte no relative pin coming so that's
how it goes Kim B one a six by Paulo
wants to play some c5 ideas in some
point and now white needs to bring the
knight see that was the main idea so you
can use the night to go to b3 and also
a5 maneuvering the Knight to b3 and to
e5 after okay that's a very very
important idea so Knight c1 castles 93
because he really wants to open that
bishop but doesn't have a good squares
to go to if you move the knight here
Knight has no future this scores are
taken okay so you go Knight c1 and 93
blocking is little bit exposed here so
because he pushed his pants a 6-bit
fascist it's a little bit of a little
bit of loose squares here and the night
is going to be placed here very well so
to go to a5 white is just very slightly
better even though this was a really
masterpiece by Kasparov to win the game
topology to play Abedin this game at all
he actually didn't play bad
you'll see they would like very it was a
very close game now he realizes the
danger here of Knight a5 and d5 is
coming ok 95 defy so that's why he takes
on default rook takes on default c5 yes
black is not going to sit there
passively he's just an advanced the
pawns now attack the rook and open up
their Bishop rook to d1 okay rook to d1
Knight b6 the pollo is playing active
putting the night on b6 and getting
ready to play d5 and break the center if
you manage to play d5 and the meantime Y
doesn't do anything he is going to have
a very nice position black white is
little bit behind in development yet
this Bishop Bishop is not developed the
rook is not developed the white needs to
do something here
g3 now he wants to be able to play this
move with the temple and check the king
King b8 what kind of move is this again
prophylactic move okay prophylactic you
know he sees there's some danger so he
goes Bishop you know he moves the King
away to safety and then so you can play
defense so remember about prophylactic
moves it's basically preventing move
okay
95 by the spot of putting pressure on
the bishop bishop
a8 and which page three now if cuspidor
manages to play one more move in ruk he1
is going to have a clear advantage okay
so you just want to try to get this
piece in so who have a nice advantage d5
comes in this is the moment to play it
if I otherwise you're not going to be
able to play this move after the rook
comes in because the capture will occur
and the Queen is hanging so d5 is played
now the position is going to get a
little bit open Queen f4 check
now this one is forcing the move King a7
because you cannot move the Queen here
the knight is dropping a knight if you
go here you run into a fork with E 5
losing a piece so same thing with the
rope so it has to go here and now rook H
e1 bring the last piece into the game
okay
the power of pushes d4 he doesn't want
to open the position obviously because
you know his king is in trouble so he
wants to just simply try to close the
position now let's think about it
white to play and find a very strong
continuation that as part of did in this
game
yes 95 let's see if that's a Kasparov
move Bravo
yes excellent 95 attacking the Queen
right excellent
now if he plays 9f takes d5 that just
loses pawn takes d5 attacking the Queen
now you take your check
losing the pawn okay
that's why he has to play with the other
night also if you take with the Bishop
you lose because of the c6 square
everyone you see that the check winning
the rock okay so from now on it's
actually everything is forced when you
look at the positional you think it if
block can take the Queen's off the board
is simply you might even win this game
positionally I mean if the Queen's come
off he's got this massive Center things
are looking really good for him if you
can just exchange the Queen's but
Kasparov calculated further here
calculating folders so let's spend a
little bit of time here and try to see
if we can find his idea here if you
retreat he is just going to take the
pawn then you can even put the night
here looking great so that's why this is
the moment that you want to spend some
time the crucial moment okay crucial
moment of the game oh the problem with
that move is I just take Y and then then
the you have to take I take your queen
and yeah I think this this could be she
you lose the pawn it's a very serious
problems your ninety five comes in black
might be even winning so you want to
leave that up a little bit later okay
lead up a little bit later okay this is
the reason why I'm showing you this game
because of this particular moment here
he did something really spectacular and
for the rest of the game it's just
brilliant yeah rookie 7 check I know I
take your queen as look I did that's the
idea yes
aha very good ideas how far did you
calculate those ideas well okay
well we're going to make that okay rook
d4 exclamation mark now if we take the
Queen he's going to take back with the
rook then he is very happy so the pallav
has to accept the sacrifice actually
sorry I shouldn't say it has to this
actually loses but here he had a
fantastic reply here he could be six and
apparently apparently this holds the
game because the knight is hanging and
anyways some computer analysis but looks
like he is holding that's why I was
saying he didn't play bad this game at
all there was just a moment where he
could have still have equality perhaps
King b6 apparently this cycle but let's
look at the fun stuff now he takes now
what do you do no this just bad yeah
this this just he takes he goes here
check 97 and
I mean the buck is just winning here up
exchange okay that's not going to work
here so now second sacrifice is going to
come into a place absolutely one it's
not enough second one is going to come
into now
brookey seven correct excellent
check second rook sacrifice now he
played the correct with King b6 this is
beautiful if it takes now check King
testicle here check can't go here
because of the bishop if it blocks with
this you just say checkmate you don't
even take a queen you just made them if
it goes Bishop d7 checkmate in q.how
checkmate he cannot take the knight
because of the pin okay excellent
so now King has to go to b6 and now
Queen d4 check King a5 look still there
is no checkmate yet you're down lotta
material but you need to find a way to
mate otherwise you're not going to win
this game so what's the continuation now
what is the idea here
absolutely it before now he comes here
now what do what are you gonna play now
do you need to get this Queen to b3 and
the game will be over how are you going
to get there huh you down lots of
material at the moment what you going to
do
quince III just want to come here simple
and say checkmate Queen takes d5
controlling the square and hoping to
swap the Queens at some point and then
we want to maybe even win the game what
you're going to do now
Brooke a7 attacking him here now Bishop
d7 only move the only move here because
how else to protect us if you protect
with the Queen he simply says checkmate
if you go rook d6 I suggested King B to
setting up setting up Queen b3 made and
we try to propose the exchange I take
you take I made okay so the power was
still not giving up there should be
seven only move the only defense
Kasparov takes the bishop he's still
down a full rook here if he can somehow
the power of change to exchange Queens
without getting made it he could win
this not win c4 yeah he spoiled it here
apparently Quincy for loses it this move
was much more difficult to deal with
okay so he played Queen c4 now what are
you going to do yes
what's the question yeah
quindi one that's going to help us King
a to checkmate
okay so Queen c4 yes okay seven the
problem is he has a route d1 check now
and then you come up it's going to take
check and goes back on these six okay
now now just take another piece now
you're only down exchange and by the way
your threating made in one here so
you're catching up with that material
deficit so ego skin takes now now what
are you gonna do Queen takes a six came
before still there is not immediately
still no immediate made here fantastic
move here needed if you don't play this
move you might even lose the game yes
you might even lose it
because he wants to go Rudy one check
and miking is now exposed
I mean White's King is also exposed now
so can you find what Kasparov played
here yes
absolutely c3 yes by the way Queen
cannot capture because it's just going
to be our maid okay King cannot come
here because
if you go to b3 then it's just check
check and yeah okay Bishop f1 with is
also here so he takes okay immediately
now
see the king was on a seven when
everything started and it's going to end
up all the way to d1 here Queen to a one
shape perfect only move you cannot go to
d3 Bishop f1 wins if you go to before
then just check if you go to a file we
need three mates or okay seven Queen B
three runs into a typical tactic check
okay so he has to go here in d2 and now
yes now if you go to e3 rookie 7 wins
yeah if you go to e-file rookie 7 wins
so he goes King D 1 now look at that it
just started all from EA to 2008 7 and
then with this arrows end up on d1 from
EA T 21 now what is the move now this is
the moment where you need to find
another fantastic move
absolutely yes now if it takes check and
then rupee seven mates can't go here if
he puts the Queen you take it and me
so he goes rook the two last efforts
last efforts now to deflect to the
flexure you know your queen last efforts
here and now one more special move
needed here still not over see the Paolo
was very resilient in this game finding
a lot of only moves I mean he played
impressively at him even though he lost
but he defended really tenaciously here
absolutely rook d7 yes deflecting this
rook he takes it take the Queen
threatening checkmate so he is forced to
take the bishop and now you see that
work all the way over there he takes it
now Queen versus rook it's not over yet
he's not giving up blocks got some
activities he's got a passport as well
Queen a8 back a sparrow but he knows how
to win this position he wants to work
with a four check now protecting f3
check f4 is coming
can't see one
Queen 87 now he wants to give a check on
g1 and pick up the pawn here and that
was it that was it no no hope anymore no
hope in this position for Topalov and
his simpler design so this was a really
really one of the bound the best games
played actually by many many specialists
consider one of the best games played
several several several decoys several
deflections
I mean humble it is just really really
unbelievable so I want to go back now to
the moment where everything started okay
and go a little bit slowly with you and
see how well you remember the idea is
the whole Drive of the King okay put the
whole Drive of the King let's see if
you're going to get all the correct
moves opening moves are not as important
to us so I'm going to go here so you
have to find about 20 correct moves here
that's very serious to find 20 correct
moves here in a row to win this game so
again if you don't find the right
continuation here you are in danger
perhaps able to lose this game because
positionally block is doing great here
he's got those pawns out there
nice majority ninth is going to capture
on d5 is going to land on it three next
move I mean you could be in serious
trouble here if you don't play that
Kasparov so who who remembers the move
here yes
rook d4 the start of the brilliant
combination he captures it what about
the second move here we remember that
one
not so many okay
you rookie seven sacrificing the second
rope that cannot be captured because of
the force may once again if captured if
captured occurs
check check mate check and mate
okay so he takes King be six now
continue King takes a five forcing the
king threatening checkmate raise your
hand now let's say Queen d5 bishop takes
the file suggestion everybody Bishop
takes d5 easy finish now easy right with
unstoppable finish Queen b3 see you're
going to even win my queen but that's
not that's not important because of the
checkmate see that that King is mated
you see the idea it's not strength right
there
so he goes here okay seven attacking the
pawn on a six Bishop d7 group takes
bishop and here we a should have played
rook H e1 and it's not so clear here I
think white is probably still winning
but it's just a lot more complicated
okay but he went
Quincy for now what did he do here what
did you do now yes
now you threaten to take on a six with a
mate King to a three
check
absolutely bishop f1 attacking a queen
absolutely and now Rock d2 deflection
through in a row huh deflecting it now
he takes it and imagine at the end of
the line the rookie salmon if the soup
was an engine block could have been
winning here seriously I mean he had to
see all this yeah he I don't know I mean
I would be interesting to ask him until
when he saw it you know you know but
would be very interesting to ask him
this question that when he sacrificed
the rook rook takes before until when
how far did his shield now he takes and
now one more time rook d3 comes in
trying to win the pawn on f3 Queen eight
check pushing the king away therefore
protect your pawn protect your pawn qc1
don't let them get their route d2 and
now excellent excellent job yes so
that's cus part of game ok cause part of
football of game ok so you can find this
game and online in many many places okay
99 oh it's okay it's closed it's closed
it's one of the best games played yes
yeah it's it's actually I don't think
there was a better game played after
that so this is it yeah it's a really a
treat to go over this game because it's
really fantastic
ok yeah
yeah okay now let's do a couple of
difficult studies okay or we'll see we
had some good two students here who were
solving the easy ones so let's get to
the hard stuff now they were saying too
easy
okay let's go this one white to play
listen carefully white to play and win
white to play and win you've got a lot
of pieces but the problem is he's got
two threads check and take so it's got
two very important threads here okay so
let's try to see what can we do here
aha we have once you have the entire
thing okay all right let's see your idea
one dat men yeah goosal check and that's
one
don't see one it's easy you should be
too and game is over them takes and just
check and wins easily so the problem is
king you want now what do you do not if
you move the King then he takes here and
then it's going to be a draw because
with the Bishop you cannot checkmate you
need another piece to checkmate with
this is another example where your own
piece is causing a problem here if this
guy was on here you would just come up
and just pick up the pawn sometimes you
have that your own piece is causing
problem okay correct but I refused to
take though I don't want to take your
knight
because if I take the knight then you're
going to check when you're going to come
up here and pick up my opponent win the
game so I will not take your piece take
losses room da check
and then if it goes away can be - and if
it goes here just come here and
sacrifice for the pawning with all right
it's a special move it's a very very
special move here that you need to find
if you cannot find this move it's going
to be a draw with three pieces versus
one pawn it's going to be a draw very
sad draw unless you can play this very
special idea if yes she's suggesting
this move everyone
what is your bread dough I mean I think
check or yeah
no I don't think I don't think you can
win this I mean because I can go like
maybe something like this yeah I don't
think so okay but where you beginning
there we're getting a little closer now
we're getting a little closer now
huh 93 ok excellent move correct now you
want to go 982 so I must take I'm sorry
if I take it's just losing ok so I must
Queen and say check to you so now he
Queen then check you and you say check
you back so you block the chip with
check kind of unusual now he goes King
do 1 this ludus of course you see a
check but he goes here Sh
ok he says I'm not resigning yet two
more moves and you have the solution
two more correct rules and you will win
correct I can't go here because of the
check again right I have to go here no
choice
rook f8 excellent job setting up the
mating net and look at that night is
covering all the squares that clinking
checkers unbelievable and now you
threatened to mate on f1 only way to
avoid that is to go here and then what
do you do check correct the s and then
you win a queen and who is the witness
very nice
or if you know how to check in with the
bishop at night you take on so on and
get a good practice you know well if you
know the process I actually showed a
couple of times I think maybe not entire
you know spend the whole thing but it
it's you going to be able to win if you
know how to write this is this is
something different okay something
different
white to play and win but the problem is
you down three pawns so if I can somehow
exchange your queen without getting made
it I cannot lose this game because you
don't have pants to Quinn a very
concrete play and also when you find the
main idea you will learn you will learn
this this tactical trick here that white
has in the beginning it's a forcing
sequence okay but in some point then
you're going to need to find a strong
quiet move forcing sequence quiet move
Queen h4 Queen f6 the h4 is okay let's
go to g6 between and six I get really
close now he comes here excellent one
more check if it was the corner Bishop
before main three goes here okay so far
so good
so far so good now one more forcing all
right we have beautiful now if you can
see we have a checkmate so he has to go
Bishop d6 and now looks like he stops it
that's it no more checks Queen h6 losses
to analysis but ego skin e7 defense it's
not Queen f6 the correct idea is Queen B
5 cross pin yeah okay down cross pin he
can take your queen it's pin he cannot
take your Bishop you take the Queen
cross pick okay now you want to take on
this issue the check so it has to go
here we got to take that Bishop first
right nobody defends he doesn't want to
just lose it what are you going to do
now
you're going to do the same idea one
more time okay
same cross Spain idea one more time
check
check
there you go look at that what we call
that tasking and most importantly cover
the d2 squared that's very important
because otherwise I would come there and
check you so you actually cover this
square so that's why you win the game
okay well okay good job everybody and
thanks for coming for the lecture and
hope to see you next week okay all right